Fred rogers was a legitimate American
national treasure over 31 seasons.
He proved to be the reliable compassion
and always friendly neighbor who guided
millions of youngsters
through that childhood.
Fred single handedly introduced
children's educational television in the
process,
elevating a medium that
was heading downhill.
Fost is radical.
Kindness typified by a gentle and personal
manner helps bring sanity to a world
beset by problems having Mr Rogers as our
neighbor made the world a safer place.
Frederick mcfeely Rogers entered
the welds on March the 28th,
19,
28 at his grandparent's house in Latrobe,
Pennsylvania.
His parents,
James and Nancy were
extremely pious people.
So young.
Fred grew up in a very
religious household.
James Works at the mcfeely brick company,
which was owned by his father.
He was a hard working industrious men
who taught these traits to his son.
Nancy volunteered at the local
hospital as a nurse's aide.
She had a deep love for helping others,
which also was a huge influence on fret.
In later years,
Fred would fondly remember how his
mother required everyone in the family to
hand knit sweaters every Christmas
for the troops during the war years.
This family ritual instilled
in fresh I love for sweaters,
and they became his trademark during his
TV show Mr Rogers neighborhood in years
to come.
Every one of the hundreds of sweaters
he wore on the show was [inaudible] by
Nancy.
The extended Roger's family was very
close with fred developing a special bond
with his grandfather.
The two spent many hours together where
the old man would encourage friends to
be himself expressing all of his
feelings and emotions freely.
This had a great impacts on Fred who
fondly recalled how his grandpa had told
him that he made his day
special by simply being himself.
Those words made fred feel special and
he made it his mission in life to how
other people feel the same way.
When he was
11,
Fred's parents adopted a
baby girl named Elaine.
Fred loved being an older brother even
though elaine proved to be quite a
handful away from the love and
the security of his family.
However,
Fred struggles,
he found it difficult to make friends,
often finding himself isolated and alone
the other children made fun of the fact
that he was overweight and that he
doesn't join in with that rough and tumble
play.
As a result,
he became rather quiet and shy.
His parents told him to
ignore the negative feelings
that were welling up inside
of him and focus on positive things.
This only made fred felt more heart
and more confused in later years.
One of his key messages to parents was
that children's feelings need to be
acknowledged rather than ignored.
The outlet that Fred
stumbled upon two releases,
pent up emotions was the piano
when he was just a few years old,
dense.
He would play the piano in
order to sooth fret by five.
He was playing it himself.
He was a natural lands within a few years.
He was so proficient that he would
play for guests and family members.
His acts would also include a puppet show.
Fred founds these outlets allowed him
to express his feelings in a way that
wouldn't upset other people.
When he was 10,
Fred's grandmother bought
in a piano of his own,
a $25 pump organ.
He spends hours each day practicing with
his time and the keys being the only
periods that he felt like he was being
his true self and his early teens.
Fred also became obsessed
with photography,
developing his own brands
in a basement darkroom.
His favorite thing to capture on film
with the expressions on other people's
faces,
the Rogers family,
they attended the Presbyterian
Church in Detroit.
From the very start,
Fred was eager and engaged.
He was entranced by every seven finding
a personal connection to the message of
Christianity and the
personality of Jesus Christ.
It inspired in him the deep felt
desire to serve and help other people.
One Fred entered high school.
He was just a shy and
unsessioned around his peers.
Whenever he did,
however,
develop a very unlikely friendship.
Friends,
it could never have imagined that he
would become close friends with someone
like Jim.
Standout.
Standout was the popular and talented
athletes and a football player when Jim
suffered a football injury.
However,
he was confined to a hospital
bed for a period of weeks.
The school assigned Fred to deliver
Jim's homework to him in hospital,
as well as making notes for him in class,
gym and Fred spent time together.
Friends came to appreciate each other.
Fred could see through
Jim's exterior images,
the sports hank and Jim could
appreciate Fred's quiet,
thoughtful nature.
When Jim was released from the hospital,
the friendship continued
through Jim's influence.
The other students came to realize
that Fred wasn't so bad after all,
Fred's hadn't changed,
but now the other students that's Mba
himself without harassing him from this,
he learns a powerful lesson that he
strived to impart to millions of children
through his TV show decades later.
The yourself without shame.
As a result of his new found
acceptance by his peers,
Fred's confidence grew
in leaps and bounds.
He became involved in school activities,
becoming editor of the school
yearbook and the newspaper.
By the end of his senior year,
he was president of the student council.
He came to the respected rather
than marks for his quiet,
thoughtful nature.
During his high school years.
Fred develops another relationship
that was pivotal in his life.
George Allen was an African
American friend of the family,
as well as sharing
Fred's passion for music.
Georgia was also a passionate pilots.
He shares his enthusiasm with threads,
teaching him to fly.
While Fred never developed
George's passion for flying,
he was in tranced by Fred's love of
imparting his aeronautical knowledge.
It was then that he learns what
it was to be a true teacher.
Upon graduating from high school,
it was Fred's intention to go to
seminary and become a minister.
This seems to be his natural calling,
allowing him to serve others just
as his parents had grieved him.
Still,
he felt a need to achieve a college degree
and his love of learning inspired him
to enroll at Dartmouth
College for his freshman year.
He decided to study the romance languages.
After a year,
however,
he decided that what he really
wanted to study with music,
Dartmouth had no program,
was worthy of Fred's talents.
So he transferred to rollins college.
It was during an initial
tour of the college that Fred
ran into his future wife,
Sandra,
Joanne,
but Sarah became hugely impressed with
Fred's piano playing ability and he
quickly became a part of
his circle of friends.
Fred majored in music composition
and minored in French language.
Prior to graduation in the summer of 1951,
Fred returned home on vacation.
He's still fully intended to attend a
theological seminary after graduation,
but everything changed when Fred saw
his first television show on the small
screen,
Fred watched is two men,
three pies into each other's faces.
In an instance,
he saw the potential in this new medium
to educate millions of people once at
the same time.
He was appalled at the low brow way that
television was currently being used.
Fred was so passionate about his desire
to change the way that television was
being used,
that he decided on the spot
to give up on his ideas,
to join the seminary and
pursue a career in television.
Upon graduating from rollins
with this music degree in hands,
Fred applied to NBC television in New
York and asked if they had any positions
available.
He was hot by a producer
named Charles Polo.
Check.
Fred moved to New York full of enthusiasm
only to find that his days were spent
running errands.
He experienced the west
and his colleagues,
especially those in positions of power.
In later years.
Fred remembered how one boss severely
chastised him in public for forgetting to
put sweetener and his coffee.
He tried mostly in vain to bring
a positive vibe to the office.
Fred's favorite NBC
show was opera theater.
The show collaborated with famous
composers to put on operas that were shown
across the nation via the tube.
Fred worked his way up to becoming
a floor manager on the show.
He was in charge of timing the programs,
making sure the cameras are ready and
letting the actors and know when to stop
and went to start.
His attentive personality allows
them to shine in this role for it.
Also became floor manager
on a handful of other shows.
He came to appreciate the wide variety
of uses that television could be put to.
One of the shows he worked
on was the Gabby Hayes show.
He watched and absorbed the lesson is
hae spoken to the camera as if there was
only one person on the
other side of the screen.
Ultimately though Fred became frustrated,
NBC wasn't showing any interest in moving
into the use of television as a medium
of education,
he decided to leave and pursue his passion
to bring music and education to the
masses,
especially children.
In 1953,
Fred and Sarah,
who had married the previous June,
heard of a new television station
that was opening in Pennsylvania.
It was to be called Wq ed.
They decided that French should apply
and he was offered a job as a program
manager.
Wq Ed was the first community
television station in the United States.
Fred saw it as the ideal opportunity
to shape educational content.
A month before w qbd was
scheduled to go live,
the owners decided that a
children's program would be
a valuable addition to the
lineup.
Fred's and the young woman
named Tracy carry the stations.
Secretary were tasked with
coming up with something.
The they came up with was
called the children's corner.
The children's corner started out very
simply while Fred worked behind the
scenes,
JC introduced free
children's educational films.
On the night before the show,
ad station director,
Dorothy Daniel gave fred
a small tiger purpose.
As a good luck charm,
fred quickly dubbed this puppet
is Daniel without telling anybody,
Fred positioned himself
behind the backdrop,
which was simply a painted sheet.
As JC began introducing the
first episode live on the air,
he cut a slit in the sheets and Danielle
appeared on screen and it's began
conversing with JC.
The bobbitt proved to be a hit with
audiences and puppets became a regular
feature of the show on this shape.
Fred's.
He was obviously the puppeteer as well
as the organ player in order to rush
between the cells and the organ he took
to wearing his trademark white tennis
shoes.
The children's going.
It became so successful,
but fred and JC became
local personalities.
The show even came to the attention of
NBC Fred's former employer when they're
head of religious programming.
When's on a four week vacation and BBC
invited Fred and JC to fly to New York to
appear live.
Every Saturday morning.
They returned to Pittsburgh
for the Monday morning show,
the NDC Saturday show now exposed
fred to a national audience.
He began receiving hundreds
of thousands of fan letters.
The NBC executives quickly secured
Fred and Josee as regulars.
They also had larger,
more professional puppets made NBC put
pressure on Fred and JC to quit w qed and
go daily on that channel,
but the power would not relinquish their
loyalty to the original channel and
they continue to travel back and forth.
Despite his grueling TV schedule,
Fred continued to pursue his dream
of achieving a theological degree.
He attended the Pittsburgh theological
seminary and studied in the late hours
finally achieving his masters in divinity.
The most influential course he took was
a masters counseling course during when
she worked with children to see how
they reacted to puppet interactions.
He found that children reacted very
differently with puppets than they would
with real people and would more easily
open up and communicate with a puppet.
Fred was ordained in 1962.
His vocation was to work with children
and families through the mass media.
Specifically,
television plans were put in action
for a Fred's hosted show for the
Presbyterian church,
but before he got off the grounds,
Fred received the call
that would change his life.
The cool came from Fred Rainsboro,
who was in charge of children's
programming in Canada.
He wanted Fred to come to Canada,
earns,
puts on a 15 minute daily show,
specifically aimed at children and using
puppets as well as his musical talents.
It was a huge risk,
Fred and Sarah,
who now had two young children,
but it was everything that Fred had
been working towards and so they bit the
bullet and moved to Toronto,
but when he arrived,
Fred was shocked to realize that Rainsboro
wants them to appear in front of the
camera rather than behind the scenes.
Rainsboro had seen Fred work one on one
with children and knew that he had a
special gift to connect with them.
Over the next 12 months.
The two Fred's develops the programs
concept with Rogers finally agreeing to
appear on screen.
The show was to be called
Mr Rogers is one word.
Rainsboro felt that this would
make it less formal to children.
The show was set up in a neighborhood
with whimsical sets and puppets for Fred
to interact with and then named.
Ernie was brought in as the Babbitt here.
The show was a huge success in Canada.
However,
after the initial 12 month
contract was up for Ed,
decided to move his family back to the
United States to be closer to family,
but even that Pittsburgh Frederick
waited patiently until Wq ed had room in
their schedule for another
children's educational program.
After two years during which he held
an education job with the church,
the funding came through for Fred
to host his own show on w qed,
Mister Rogers' neighborhood.
The show premieres in October
of 1966 for the first year.
It was essentially a rehashing of the
Canadian version of Mr Rogers within 12
months.
However,
the format had expanded and the show had
been picked up by the sears company as
a major sponsor,
enabling it to go to a national audience.
Frederick wrote the theme song,
which was to become famous.
Won't you be my neighbor?
The revamped show added more characters,
puppets,
and places to visit each episode.
Fred would go out of the
studio and visit a new place.
The second national series in 1969 rolled
out in full color in the third season.
The show which had become hugely popular,
was taken over by the Public
Broadcasting Service or PDS.
The first round of Mr Rogers neighborhood
continue to production for a total of
eight seasons and 455 episodes.
By then Fred's.
He was ready to take a break and
so the show transitioned to reruns,
but Fred's.
We're still busy ever.
The perfectionist,
he took the opportunity to fix things
that he didn't like from older episodes.
New original seasons of Mr Rogers
neighborhood began filming in 1979.
Between then and 1990 3:15 new episodes
were produced per season which shows
linking together and carrying through
one overall theme for the entire season.
The huge popularity over the
show was due to Fred's casual,
inviting and empathetic nature.
He never acted,
always striving to be genuine and honest.
His main method of teaching
was through his own example.
As many of as audience
members grew up with him,
the show would starts with Fred's talking
directly to his child audience about
the subjects.
Then it would transition to a field
trip which had been filmed earlier.
Then it would be back live where Fred
would move into the neighborhood of make
believe this was a whimsical place
where the characters could learn,
explore them,
and to act out specific scenarios.
Then Fred would move out
of the neighborhood of make
believe and discuss what
had happened in the neighborhood
that day from start to finish.
The emphasis of the show
was on communication,
opening up to others
and exploring feelings.
Fred was not afraid to discuss any
topic that was relevant to children,
including divorce and death.
In addition to these heavy topics,
Fred also encouraged children to have
fun exploring the world around them and
keeping that curiosity alive in 2001.
Fred retired at the age of 71
after 31 seasons and 865 episodes.
If Mr Rogers neighborhood,
the show was officially over,
but Mr Rogers was still a
familiar tv because of reruns.
Yes.
Who was best known for
his landmark TV show,
Fred Rogers invested his time and
energy into other work as well.
He was involved in the
Children's book business,
held seminars for parents and produced
many documentary style features.
The most well known of these
was a series called Mr Rogers,
heroes and old friends,
new friends for the show.
Fred's traveled all over the United
States talking to admirable people.
Fred authored a total of 36 children's
books dealing with issues ranging from
fear of going to the
hospital to potty training.
Fred's passion for children's education
led to his involvement in advocacy work
in 1979.
He founded a nonprofit organization
called Family Communications,
Inc.
He also made his voice heard on the
national level when he became involved in
government issues.
In 1969,
He appealed to a group of senators in an
effort to stop the federal government's
cutting funding to pbs.
Largely as a result of his efforts,
the funding was actually
increased by $10,000,000 in 1984.
He was called as an expert witness in a
case between sony and the universal city
studio.
The case was about the new sony
technology called beta max,
which was the forerunner
of the video recorder.
This new technology threatens hollywood's
and universal brought the case to stop
sony on the grounds of copyrights.
Fred testified on behalf of sony stating
the importance of parents and children
being able to tape his
show for viewing later.
Sony ultimately won the case
a year after his
retirement from television.
Fred was diagnosed with stomach cancer.
His last public appearance was when he
tossed the coin at the 2003 rose bowl.
A few weeks later,
he underwent surgery to
get rid of the cancer.
It was unsuccessful and fred when time
to spend his last weeks with his family,
he died on february the 27th,
2003 surrounded by his
family and his devoted wife,
sarah fred's passing was
warned around the world,
but it was felt the hardest
and his native pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
His memorial was held there and it
was attended by thousands of people,
including many celebrities.
Pbs took steps to help children to come
to terms with the loss of Mr. Rogers.
They continue to our reruns
and a special insight,
or fred rogers,
america's favorite neighbor,
was hosted by michael
keaton during his lifetime.
Fred receIved many awards including the
presidential medal of freedom in 1999.
He was inaugurated into the television
hall of fame and one of his sweaters was
featured in the smithsonian institute
as a treasure of american history.
The greatest legacy of fred rogers
is the show that made him a national
treasure.
The lessons he imparted of tolerance,
compassion,
love,
and empathy are just as relevant today
as they were when Mr. Rogersrogers'
neighborhood first went
to add in the 19 sixties.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every monday and every thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button
next to the subscribe button.
That'll send you a
notification every time,
every monday and thursday
when we put out a new video.
also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the rice and as always,
thank you for watching.